Guess what Kelly told me last night? She and Ben are selling their home. It's a beautiful property, great location, new kitchen
I think they'll give us the listing. That'd be great, honey. We can't be realtors if we don't have listings
Oh shit. Someone's coming. Hurry
Act casual
Our life was amazing, but something happened to my wife
I can't feel my heartbeat. What?
She threw up this. I didn't have formaldehyde so I saved it in olive oil
That was a crazy amount of ramen
Well, I'm not a medical expert
It was a huge amount
She's acting different
I can cook that for you, sweetheart
I'm fine
Did mom die?
She is dead and also undead
A zombie?
I don't like that word. I think it's inherently negative
I don't like it either
Then let's not use it
I do like the way that I feel
I have endless energy and I sleep two hours a night. I get so much done
You eat people. I know. It's just that I'm so much more confident. I can parallel park in one move now
The undead aren't completely driven by their it
But if I can't control myself then I risk everything that matters to me
We're not saying you have to do this alone sweetheart
I'm are not going to bail on you now
We have to kill someone who deserves it. I guess the prototype would be a young single hitler. God, We'd be heroes
Shit! You guys are not great at this. From now on, we fuck everything up together
What kind of realtor are you? Residential but commercial on request
So my wife's been on this new diet
She feels good, looks fantastic, and has all kinds of energy. She is really happy so it's all great
Well, maybe not all great. You know there's some stuff going on
That's kind of intense. Like the other day we were at the park
And she got hungry
And there's this jerk throwing rocks at the ducks
If you've tried all the other diets and are looking for the one that really works, then the Santa Clarita diet is for you
Lose as much weight as you want and keep it off forever. No gimmicks. Just great results
It's easy and your family will love the new you
But no one saw us
And you know, the guy was being a dick to the ducks. The Santa Clarita diet, it's great
Get the first month free